sword banking has always been an
esoteric endeavor
there's never been a great number of
people doing it
you have this transformation of raw
material
the alteration of nature
and in the end you get something that
just exudes
power
this is valyrian steel
it's my father's sword
the ancient swords on game of thrones
forged with valerian steel were stronger
and lighter than any other weapon
no one knows how they were made
in the real world over a thousand years
ago in viking lands there was also a
series of special swords with mysterious
origins
and a blacksmith in wisconsin tried to
make one
this is an olf birth sword
from about 8 50 to maybe early 1200s in
viking controlled lands you had a sword
that had a name inlay called wolfbert
which roughly translates to a wolf tooth
or wolf bear
it's a word of power
there are only 350 known ulfboard swords
forged with the quality of steel that
didn't emerge in europe for another
thousand years no one knows exactly how
they were made
i think i've come fairly close or at
least a pretty good rendition of how
they made those blades
steel is a pretty special material we
know a great deal about it and we know
almost nothing about it
so with the ulfbert you have a mythical
steel mirrored in the game of thrones
where you have this steel that no one's
able to reproduce that black valerian
steel
sword making technology still holds a
bit of alchemy a bit of mysticism in it
we want to believe that there's
something
that we can't understand
there's still mysteries in steel
you